In today’s big data context, the previous
approaches are either incomplete or suboptimal.
For example, the SEMMA methodology
disregards completely data collection
and preprocessing of different data sources.
These stages normally constitute most of
the work in a successful big data project.
We begin by realizing that there are two sides
to the analytics life cycle – discovery and
deployment. Let’s take a look at the tasks
for both sides and see how they interact to
create an iterative process that you can use to
produce repeatable, reliable predictive results.
The Discovery Phase of the Analytics Life Cycle
The first phase is the discovery
phase of the analytics life cycle:
• Ask a question. The discovery process
is driven by asking business questions
that produce innovations. So, the first step
is defining what the business needs to know.
And then translating the business question into
a mathematical representation of the problem,
which can be solved with predictive analytics.
Business people also need to specify the need,
scope, market conditions and goals related
to a business question they are trying to
answer – which helps in the selection of
the most appropriate modeling techniques.
• Prepare the data. Technologies like Hadoop
and faster, cheaper computers have made it
possible to store and use more data, and
more types of data, than ever before.
But this has only amplified the need
to join data in different formats from
different sources and transform raw data so that
it can be used as input for predictive modeling.
With new data types from connected devices,
such as machine sensor data or web logs from
online interactions, the data preparation
stage has become even more challenging.
Many organizations still report that they spend
an inordinate amount of time, sometimes up to
80 percent, dealing with data preparation
tasks. The majority of time in the discovery
phase should be spent on exploring data and
creating good models instead of preparing data.
• Explore the data. Interactive, self-service
visualization tools need to serve a wide range
of users, from the business analyst
with no statistical knowledge to
the analytically savvy data scientist, so
they can easily search for relationships,
trends and patterns to gain deeper understanding
of the data. In this step, the question and the
approach formed in the initial “ask” phase of the
project will be refined. Ideas on how to address
the problem from an analytical perspective are
developed and tested. While examining the data,
you may find the need to add, delete or combine
variables to create more precisely focused models.
Fast, interactive tools help
make this an iterative process,
which is crucial for identifying
the best questions and answers.
• Model the data. In this stage, numerous
analytical and machine-learning modeling
algorithms are applied to the data to find the
best representation of the relationships in the
data that will help answer the business question.
Analytical tools search for a combination of data
and modeling techniques that reliably predict
a desired outcome. There is no single algorithm
that always performs best. The “best” algorithm
for solving the problem depends on the data.
Experimentation is key to finding the most
reliable answer, and automated model building
can help minimize the time to results and boost
the productivity of analytical teams. In the past,
data miners and data scientists were only able
to create several models in a week or month using
manual model-building tools. Improved software and
faster computers have sped up the model-building
process so hundreds or even thousands of
models can be created today in the same time
frame. But that brings to the surface another
issue. How to quickly and reliably identify the
one model that performs best? Model “tournaments”
provide a way to compare many different competing
algorithms with the opportunity to choose the one
that provides the best results for a specific set
of data. With automated tournaments of
machine-learning algorithms and clearly
defined metrics to identify the champion model,
this has become an easier process. Analysts and
data scientists can spend their time focusing
on more strategic questions and investigations.
The Deployment Phase of the Analytics Life Cycle
The second phase is the deployment
phase of the analytics life cycle:
• Implement your models. This is where you take
the insights learned from the discovery phase
and put them into action using repeatable,
automated processes. In many organizations this is
the point where the analytical modeling process
slows dramatically because there is no defined
transition between discovery and deployment,
or collaboration between the model developers
and IT deployment architects, much less optimized
automation. In most organizations the deployment
environment is very different from the discovery
environment, especially when the predictive models
are supporting operational decision making. Often,
IT has to apply rigorous governance policies
to this environment to ensure service-level
agreements with the business. By integrating the
discovery and deployment phases, you can create
an automated, flexible and repeatable transition
that improves operational decisions. Additionally,
a transparent, governed process is important for
everyone – especially auditors. Once built, the
model is registered, tested or validated, approved
and declared ready to be used with production
data (embedded into operational systems).
• Act on new information. There are two types of
decisions that can be made based on analytical
results. Strategic decisions are made by humans
who examine results and take action, usually
looking to the future. Operational decisions are
automated – like credit scores or recommended
best offers. They don’t require human intervention
because the rules that humans would apply can be
coded into the production systems. More and more
organizations are looking to automate operational
decisions and provide real-time results to
reduce decision latencies. Basing operational
decisions on answers from analytical models also
makes these decisions objective, consistent,
repeatable and measurable. Integration of models
with enterprise decision management tools enables
organizations to build comprehensive and
complete operational decision flows. These
combine analytical models with business-rule-based
triggers to produce the best automated decisions.
And because this is formally defined
within the decision management tool,
updates and refinements to changing conditions are
easy – improving business agility and governance.
Once approved for production, the decision
management tool applies the model to new
operational data, generating the predictive
insights necessary for better actions.
• Evaluate your results. The next and perhaps
most important step is to evaluate the outcome
of the actions produced by the analytical model.
Did your models produce the correct predictions?
Were tangible results realized, such as
increased revenue or decreased costs?
With continuous monitoring and measurement of the
models’ performance based on standardized metrics,
you can evaluate the success of
these assets for your business.
That evaluation can then feed
the next iteration of the model,
creating a continuous machine-learning loop. If
you identify degradation of analytical models, you
can define the optimal strategy to refresh them
so they continue to produce the desired results.
With increasing numbers of analytical models,
automation is necessary to quickly identify
models that need the most attention,
and even deliver automated retraining.
• Ask again. Predictive models are not forever.
The factors that drive the predictions in a model
change over time, your customers change over time,
competitors enter or leave the market, and new
data becomes available. You have to refresh even
the most accurate models, and organizations will
need to go through the discovery and deployment
steps again. It’s a constant and evolving process.
If a model degrades, it is recalibrated by
changing the model coefficients or rebuilt with
existing and new characteristics. When the model
no longer serves a business need, it is retired.
In summary, in an effective analytical
environment, data is rapidly created and accessed
in the correct structure for exploration and model
development. Models are rapidly built and tested,
and deployed into a production environment
with minimal delay. Production models quickly
generate trusted output. Model performance is
constantly monitored, and underperforming models
are quickly replaced by more up-to-date models. In
short, a successful analytics strategy means more
than creating a powerfully predictive model; it
is about managing each of these lifecycle stages
holistically for a particular model and across
the entire portfolio of models. This is no easy
feat. Consider that analysts and data scientists
don’t just develop one model to solve a problem.
They develop a set of competing models and use
different techniques to address complex problems.
They will have models at various stages
of development and models tailored for
different product lines and business problems.
An organization can quickly find itself managing
thousands of models. Furthermore, the model
environment is anything but static. Models
will be continually updated as they are tested
and as new results and data become available.
The goal is to build the best predictive
models possible, using the best data available.